all right eighty takers any thoughts hmm
this is a tough part this is a tough
part let me ask a reading question what
does it mean for an equation to be
tangent to this parabola right like we
already know it doesn't just mean that
it's um it just no actually I'm not even
gonna give you a clue I was gonna give
you a clue and then I realize it would
spoil the answer what makes this line at
agent I could draw an infinite number of
lines on this plane what's special about
this line that said that you can say hey
that's a tangent to the preneur it
touches just once you can be a bit more
specific than that as well right because
I could draw a line like say this yeah
if that were the line it also touches
just once but it's clearly not a tangent
it goes straight through okay so what
does it do in addition to just touching
once what is it that this line has that
this line does not have even though they
both just touch once see this not
tangent right touches just once but at
this spot where it touches there the
tangent sorry they're not tangent and
the parabola do you see there they're
not going in the same direction right
there are ones going this way and ones
going that way okay
whereas when you have a look at the
tangent and this is something that I was
talking about with the with the
satellite dish and all that kind of
thing at that point right there the
tangent and the parabola might as well
be the same line they they share the
same gradient okay so this is a really
important idea to know just overall the
thing that makes it a tangent the thing
that makes it just touch is that it has
the same gradient at the point of
intersection okay so how can I use all
these ideas to find out what a is
right well if I were to try and find
that point if I were to try and find
that point what would I do what would I
actually do
I suppose you actually knew what the
equation of this parabola was suppose
I'm just gonna make something up so it
was like x squared minus 3x plus 2
whatever okay if that word the equation
and I asked you to find the equation
that the coordinates at that point what
would you actually do to find them you'd
solve simultaneously because what you
want is the parabola and the equation to
be at the same place at the same time
hence simultaneous okay now the thing is
you don't know the exact equation of
this parabola but you know a lot about
it right so you're not like totally I've
got no idea so let's see what happens
let's see what happens if I take what I
know to at least be true right which is
not the whole picture but it's a lot and
go ahead and do what you suggest to try
and solve simultaneously now I've got
this equation here I'll just call this
one and I'll call this to I've because
the subject of equation one is why I can
just substitute it into equation 2 right
it's all gonna do exactly that
I'm gonna sub 1 into 2 well you're
solving some seriously you should always
say in what way you're doing that okay
by the way are you are you going blind
is that joining put this down you guys
okay yeah okay just solution all right
so everywhere I see why I'm gonna
substitute it for minus 4x plus 7 let's
do that so I get this minus 4x plus 7
okay that's fine now this thing here
what's your instinct what what could I
do with this remember what I'm trying to
do I'm trying to get to what a value of
a right what I do with this thing
make if I make a this subject let's
think about before we embark on that
path let's see what would happen if I
make Dada Dada Dada do lots of working
and then get a equals right well be on
the right hand side what stuff will be
on the right hand side there will be
lots of X's and lots of other numbers
presumably okay now that's a bit of a
problem for me because I don't know
anything about X right well X can be
anywhere I like okay so even if I get to
such a point where a is the subject this
stuff over here will be unhelpful to me
okay
so therefore I'm a bit stuck however I
want to remember
sorry a bit stuck with that strategy I
want to remember what you guys told me
before which is that what makes it a
tangent is that it touches exactly once
shares the same gradient okay so okay
yeah I'm going to expand this thing
rather than actually going to the
derivative because there's no Y here
anymore so I can't do do you want yes
I'm actually going to use something else
that you guys know from quadratics
quadratics right I'm going to use not
the derivative but the discriminant okay
the dish right when I have exactly one
point of intersection
I'm expecting a discriminant that's
equal to zero
do you remember that if a quadratic has
a descriptive zero there is exactly one
solution greater than zero two solutions
less than zero no solutions equals zero
one solution the one that I want okay so
to find the discriminant we of course
know the discriminant is b squared minus
4ac so I need to know what a and B and C
are in this particular quadratic it's
it's a mess right now
I can't it's not in general form so I
need to change that let's do it this is
x squared minus 6x plus 9 over here
what's this
help me out expand for me good
good okay fantastic now I'm just going
to note I've got a whole bunch of terms
here I'm looking for an A and a being a
see right so you can see the a is gonna
be one there's only a single x squared
term the bees are going to come from
here and here so I'm gonna collect like
terms in a second and then the C's come
from what's left these guys are the
constants does that make sense
so now I know where I'm going the next
line not line I'm going to write it in
ax squared plus BX plus C for yeah
that's a great question so what I'm
looking for is something that looks like
this I'm going to use capitals because
I've got the letter A here okay so
therefore the the constant is anything
which has no X is attached this has no X
is attached and even though this has a
pruning rule it's not X it's it's a
different one
so let's rearrange them I've got my x
squared I'll make it 1 X square because
that's what a is they say anyway how
many X's do I have well I'm gonna have
negative 6 here and remember I should
write this this one first I'm adding to
get it all on the same side so I'm gonna
write that first because it's positive
16 a minus 6 that's how many X's I've
got do you agree and then what do I have
for the constant I've got 9 already and
I'm going to subtract 28 a that equals
zero okay happy times so now I know what
I can put into here right the
discriminant is going to be equal to B
squared minus 4 ay C okay yeah and I
know that this thing should be equal to
zero okay so I can go ahead and I can
crunch this out but that's that's that's
going to get me my value of a out of
there
okay do you want to do that together or
do you want to have a easy you can have
it go on your own here's what I suggest
have a go on your own I will point out
when I look at this unlike her that's a
bit weird because do you notice this is
a quadratic in it's a quadratic so I'm
sort sort of expecting a to be this or
this right I am guessing I don't know
100 cent cuz I don't know what these
numbers are going to give me I am
guessing one of these will be negative
and we have said that a is a length so
therefore you will exclude one of the
answers and you'll just end up with one
because it doesn't look to me like you
can come up with two parabolas that will
give you the right equation okay